e
it's
done now so it's over good news so
here's what's going to
happen here's what's going to happen
next Chris and Zoe are going to take the
quizzes up to my office it's going to go
in alphabetical order and they going to
leave it on my desk and sometime soon I
will start grading them so I will grade
and grade until I get done grading and
when I'm done grading I will let you
know the quizzes are graded and you can
come pick them up they will be faced
down and I'll tell you where to go find
them in alphabetical order right so this
isn't borders no browsing through you
know where your name is pick your quiz
up I can't think of an efficient way in
which I can return these quizzes without
sucking up a lot of my class time the
reason I asked you to write your name on
the back was that so if you didn't not a
big deal I will copy your name but it
makes it less work for me if you've
written your name and both places the
front and the back so it'll be face down
alphabetically when I send you the quiz
the email saying your quizzes are done I
will also send you the Excel spreadsheet
with my Solutions and a grading template
okay I'll tell you up front I grade
quickly and I grade noisily what does
that mean I just get it through so this
isn't building an aircraft yesterday I
was in a you know on a Boeing aircraft
coming from Portugal zero defects I was
what I was looking for this one I'm
willing to accept I will make mistakes
so here's what I want you to do if you
see a mistake and the grading template
not clearly shows that I've made a
grading mistake don't [__] and mourn
about it don't stew in your juices just
say look you made a mistake I'll fix it
and we'll move on okay on the multiple
choice I have an answer but I'm willing
to listen to your answer if you feel
that you have a basis for the answer but
I'm not a pushover so if you give me
another answer I'll push back and if you
can show me that there is a basis for
your answer I will go along so I am not
the
Pope I am fallible so in a sense if you
push back and I can think of a good
reason why your answer might be right no
so we you know so watch out for that
email saying your quizzes are done it
will come sooner than you think okay
because I have three quizzes today 650
quizzes so my job is to get your quizzes
back to you because I want you know
taking up room in my office and you know
I want to get them back to you so watch
out for that
email I know you're in no mood to kind
of listen more about Corporate Finance
but you have no choice okay so today
we're going to move on from the cost of
equity to the cost of capital so Equity
is one way of raising Capital right
what's the other way of raising Capital
you can borrow money so today I want to
focus in on what exactly goes into debt
sounds like a silly question you're
saying I can see it on the balance sheet
but I'm going to give you what I'd look
for to classify something as dead and
you're already going to see that
accountants don't always call things
that are debt as debts it might not show
up and then we're going to try to attach
a cost to the debt how do we get a cost
over Equity we started with the risk
free rate then we came up with an equity
risk premium then we estimated beta in
fact we that whole dance we need a cost
of debt luckily that dance is a little
less involved but we need a cost of debt
along the way we've got to deal with the
hypocrisy of governments that tell
people not to borrow money and then
write a tax code that encourages you to
borrow money and how it shows up in your
cost of capital so let's get the first
component of these these process in
place when I think about debt I think
about a contractual
obligation whe it shortterm or longterm
I don't care if I have a contractual
obligation I have essentially the
equivalent of debt so when I look at a
fin at a company's balance sheets I'm
going to look at any interest bearing
obligation you have and treat it as
debt until 2019 if you were a retailer
or a restaurant you were able to borrow
money and not show it in your balance
sheet in what way you entered into a
lease a 12E lease a 15year lease
contractual obligation yeah you signed a
lease contract but until 2019
accountants and whatever for whatever
reason decided not to treat as that
we're not bound by accounting rules so
no IFRS or Gap looking over our
shoulders we're essentially going to
treat any contractual obligation
including Lisa's debt now that
accountants have come around you say why
should I have to do this sometimes you
might disagree with what accountants
have treated as that and there are other
items like leases that you might want to
treat as that other contractual
obligations so with that in place let's
talk about estimating the cost of debt
I'll you know whenever you you know in
finance You' run into Customs best to go
back to First principles the cost of
debt that is in a cost of capital is the
rate at which you can borrow money
longterm today let me let me repeat that
again the cost of debt is the rate at
which you can borrow money longterm
today two key words that that today and
longterm let's take the Today
part you can show me all the debt on
your books right you borrowed two years
ago 5 years ago 7 years ago I don't care
why because you were in a different
circumstance rates were different I care
about the rate at which you can borrow
money today why
longterm you can borrow shortterm as a
company and sometimes it makes sense for
you to borrow short-term your working
capital needs you might take six month
loans I fully accept that and much of
the time in the last century Maybe not
right now when you borrowed money
shortterm as opposed to long term there
was a term structure for interest rates
right which rate was usually lower
short-term rates or long-term
rates short-term rates were usually
lower in 95 or the last 10 years the
yield curve has been upward sloping what
does that mean when you borrow one year
it's lower than a 10year
loan so if you borrow money shortterm
the rate will look lower right and you
want me to give you the benefit of that
lower rate and a cost of capital and I'm
going to say no I can't do that why is
that you are borrowing at a lower rate
why am I not giving you the
credit or you got to reinvest when you
take a oneye loan to run a business not
like you're one and done you're going to
have to come back next year the year
after the year after the year after at
what rates essentially it's not even the
risk issue when you think about forward
rates so way we get forward rates you
take a long-term rate and we roll into
into the forward rates the rolled over
cost of your one-year loan over 10 years
is going to be roughly equal to the 10
year cost of debt so I'm not saying you
can't borrow money shortterm but I'm
going to attach a long you know what
this makes your life very easy because
now when you look at debt you take all
debt short-term as well as long-term and
you attach a long-term current cost you
saying how the heck are we going to get
a long-term current cost you play the
role of a banker and I'm going to be a
us company
and I'm going to come to borrow money
from you right now when you lend me
money what's the absolute lowest number
you would charge me what's the base from
which you're going to build
off the risk fre rate the t-bond rate
right why t-bond because you're looking
at longterm right now it's about 4.25
notice it's
4.23% this morning if you remember just
two weeks ago it was
4.6% we talked about things shifting
while you're watching them so 4.25% will
you lend me money at
4.25% if you did you you wouldn't last
very long as a bank right why
not why can't you lend to a company at
the same rate as a treasury rate because
I'm at
default and there are differences in
default risk across companies so the
cost of Deb boils down to it's very
focused unlike cost of back you get
distracted by what country do you
operate in what your businesses with the
cost of debt you only one question will
you pay me will you pay me will you pay
me and everything you do is about hey
will you pay me so when you look at me
as a company and you want to assess that
credit risk remember banks have been
doing this for as long as there been
banks on the face of the Earth what are
some of the things you will look
at
Derek I'm going to look you're going to
look at my history if I have a history
of defaulting every two or three years
you're going to say well you probably
have a lot of default risk
right I mean if you're an individual
this is what credit score kind of gives
away about you right so you're going to
look at my history what else
RI before you look at that what do I
need to what do I use to pay the debt
what I earned right it'll be nice if I
have lots of earnings because so you're
going to look at what I generate as
earnings will you care about the
stability of that
number you can to choose so so what else
would you want to look
at you're going to also look at other
other obligations for my earnings you're
going to look at my earnings you're
going to look at the stability of the
earnings you're going to see other
claims on those earnings why because you
want to make sure you don't end up last
person in line not be able to collect
and after all of that you charge me a
spread over and above the risk rate
let's call it a default spread for lack
of a better word or a credit spread and
that credit spread is going to be wider
if I if you see more default risk in me
than if I'm safer everybody agrees so
far so this you don't need to take a
finance class you lend money to somebody
this is your first question will you pay
me back and if you're concerned about me
paying being paying back you charge me a
high interest
rate you each picked a company you've
going to come up with this question what
is the default risk in my company for
some of your companies your life is
going to be easy because somebody
else would have done this for you
whatever you talking
about a ratings agency S&P Moody Fitch
has attached a rating I know it's sloppy
you're taking somebody else's assessment
think of how much work it saves you so
for those of you with companies with
ratings don't look a gift TS in the
mouth you have a rating you can convert
that rating into a default spread why if
you have a rating is it so easy to
convert into a default
Rima if you told me a is Triple B why am
I able to gauge what your default spread
is based on the
rating it's gives you a benchmark but I
need to convert that Benchmark into a
number so what can I see in markets that
allows me to do are there tripleb rated
companies that are traded out there you
can see what people are charging as
default spreads the advantage of having
a rating is even if your debt is not
traded there are others out there with
debt that's traded bonds that are traded
and you can look up the spread that
those so this number will it change over
time this those
spreads did Equity risk creams change
over time what caused them to change
fear and greed you think the Bond Market
is immune from those things default
spreads are going to go up and down but
basically you give me a rating I can
tell you what the default spread is
right now I add that on to my t- B rate
I'm done think of how much simpler this
is than the beta Equity risk prum
debts one you know you open that door
you're saying if I have bonds traded why
can't I just look up the yield to
maturity on a bond that I've issued
right AT&T as as bonds outstanding now
that doesn't that give me a cost of debt
maybe and here's why you should be
cautious about you looking at the yield
to maturity of a bond that your
company's issue can a risky company
issue a safe Bond
when you buy a bond it's backed up by
something right as a company if I carve
out my safest assets and back up your
bond your bond can be very safe even
though I'm a risky as a company the
danger of using a single Bond and taking
the yield to maturity is depending on
how that bond is structured if you take
that rate and extrapolate to the whole
company you will come up with a cost of
debt that's too low the nice thing about
having a bond traded though is you will
have a rating so when you have a bond
trading trade rather than use yield to
maturity go with the
rating so I was just doing this a couple
of weeks ago I was looking up the rate
ratings for every rated company in the
world there are about 2,500 rated
companies the US is
disproportionately represented because
the bond market is deepest here there
are 48,000 publicly traded companies in
the world 2500 of ratings and I gave you
an easy way you saying what the heck do
we do with the other $45,000
500 here's what you cannot do and many
people use this they say I don't have a
rating I can't come up with the default
spread so I'm going to use a book
interest rate you know what a book
interest rate is you take the interest
expense you divide by the book value of
debt what does that reflect the rates at
which you borrowed money and it also
reflects whether you short-term or
long-term it's a non-starter it is not a
long-term forward-looking cost of debt
so if you have a company that doesn't
have a rating you got to act like a
ratings agency and before your stomach
drops ratings agencies are the most
transparent entities in the world not
because they want to but because of what
they make
public so you look at S&P or moodies
they give you the rating of every
company that they rate right it's in the
public
domain they also give away the game they
say look we look at mostly public
information and these are the ratios we
use in fact on the S&P website on the
the cover page they listed the eight
ratios they used they included things
like you know eidar by fixed charges
looking at noima Point abouty what other
the charges are there they looked at you
know how much debt the company already
has so pretty Common Sense ratios so
they tell you what the rating of every
rating rated company is they give you
the eight ratios that they used to come
up with the rating so in the early '90s
when I said I want to come up with a way
of estimating the cost of debt for
non-rated companies I did some reverse
engineering I took the rated companies I
took the eight ratios they claimed to
use all public information and then I
looked to see whether there were clues
in the ratios I could use to guess the
rating we're going to call this a
synthetic rating process synthetic
because we're coming up with the rating
so I initially looked at all eight
ratios and then I said well I don't know
whether all of these ratios matter as
much how do I tell which ratios are
carrying the load and which ones are
along for the right and that's a purely
statistical question right you look at
the difference in ratings you look at
the difference in ratios one by one I
started Crossing out ratio said that
doesn't seem to matter that doesn't seem
to matter and ultimately I narrow it
down to one
ratio which for non-financial service
companies explains about 50 to 60% of
the differences in ratings across
companies it's called the interest
coverage
ratio you know what the interest
coverage ratio is it's operating income
EIT earnings before interest and taxes
divided by the interest expense Think
Like A lender you want that number to be
a high number or a low number you're
lending to somebody you want a high
interest coverage ratio or a low
interest coverage ratio you want it to
be as high as possible because it gives
you buffer so we're going to talk about
estimating ratings for non-rated compan
compies but once I estimate a rating I
go through the same process one final
Point by the time you get to the cost of
debt you've already made some choices
right remember when you did cost of
equity I said you got to choose a
currency you're valuing a Russian
company you decide to do things in Euros
you can do everything in yours you get
to the cost of debt you're locked in by
that
choice you know what causes people to
get confused here is they look at the
currency a company borrows it and I say
I have to compute the cost of debt in
that currency and you that's okay but if
that's different from the currency in
which you estimate your cost of equity
can't mix the
two so you got to make the same currency
choice you do with the cost of equity so
I'm going to start with my easy
companies first the companies where I
had a rating I'm going to confess that I
trusted the ratings agencies up front
and then I'll go talk about how you
might want to test that trust so three
of my companies had ratings Disney and
deuts had single a ratings V had an A
minus rating so they're S&P ratings I
could use Moody's ratings don't don't
worry too much about it 98% of companies
the S&P and Moody's ratings are actually
very very similar so there's actually a
table I have where you can see what a
Moody's rating transer into an S&P
rating there there so when there's
disagreements there small disagreements
you're not going to get piig one so pick
a rating sayy get the rating and in 2013
those r readings gave me default spreads
of 1% for the single a rated companies
and 1.3% for the a minus rated companies
I'm done I've got my risk free rate
remember it was 10 the I'm doing all you
know in this case Disney and valy and US
dollars I used the US dollar RC rate
added the default spread to it I have my
pre-tax cost of
debt for those two companies for do I
was doing everything in Euros I started
with the Euro risk free rate I add the
default spread to it I have a pre-tax
cost of debt so the default spread goes
on top of whatever currency risk free
rate you've chosen to use I come up with
the pre-tax cost of debt and in the case
of R if I want to convert my dollar cost
of debt into a re cost of debt by now
this equation should be familiar what do
I do I bring in the differential
inflation so if at this stage you say I
want a cost of debt and real it's not a
big deal I take the dollar cost of debt
4.05% and and I convert it into a re
cost of debt by bringing in the extra 7%
inflation rate okay so I don't even know
what this take that out of the no is
equal to 11.19 that should be out of
there so it's
1.45 scaled up for the additional
inflation so I've got a cost of debt for
my companies for which I have a
rating saying what about the rest of my
companies I'm going to use the interest
coverage rate
I have the interest coverage ratio for
each of these companies remember you can
compute this for public private it's
just a bit earnings before interest in
taxes divided by interest expense so I
computed the interest coverage
ratio for all of the companies including
my rated companies you saying you
already were rating why bother I wanted
to see if I got a synthetic rating for
these companies whether it was pretty
close to the S&P rating and if it wasn't
what I might be missing that S&P had
caught on or what S&P might be missing
that I might have caught with the ratio
so there's my interest coverage ratio
for five of my six
companies so operating income divided by
interest expense interest coverage ratio
just looking at the interest coverage
ratio if I ask you which of these
companies would you feel safest lending
to and Disney and Buu are way up there
you saying but Buu is a risky company it
is but borrow so little money you still
have 23.7 it could have its income drop
by 50% you're still going to be okay
could have its income drop by9 90%
you're still going to get paid so
clearly it's taken into account the
riskiness and how much it borrows and
the riskiest company here would be T mod
is the lowest interest coverage ratio
but interest coverage ratios don't give
me default spreads I've got to take this
interest coverage ratio and convert it
into a rating right so start of every
year I do a lookup you tell me what your
interest coverage ratio is I'll guess
your rating this lookup table is pure
data there's no Theory remember those 25
rated companies I created and at the
ratios basically this lookup table came
from looking at those 2500 company
saying what do I need to get a AAA
rating and I noticed that life wasn't
fair there if you are a large company
and I'm going to Define large as a
market cap greater than 5 billion the
ratings agencies were much much more
lenient on you they gave you a higher
rating for a particular interest
coverage ra smaller company so I created
two lookup tables one for large
companies and one one for small
ones so let's take Disney large cap
develop Market company that's your best
case scenario big company in the
developed Market their interest coverage
ratio is
that overrating you go to Val large cap
Emerging Market
company and again I'm going to use the
life as unfair argument if you're an
Emerging Market company you're treated
like a small cap company by the ratings
agencies the rating they get with
11.67 is a doublea rating small cap or
risky so with each company I look at
whether the large cap or small cap
emerging or developed and take the
interest coverage ratio and I get a
synthetic rating now I have a rating for
each of my companies including the rated
companies but for the unrated companies
I have a estimate of what I think their
rating would be so I took a pause and I
said why is my rating different than the
S&P rating let's go through some of the
things I will miss when I use just the
interest coverage ratio to estimate the
rating for a
company any
ideas Yousef what might I miss if I just
use the interest coverage ratio so
you're a lender right you're basing just
an interest coverage ratio what are some
of the things
I
yes and what my because remember we have
to stick with number based numbers right
because you can't do this individually
for companies and you can't so one of
the things that you might look at is
this is last year's interest coverage
rate ratio if you have a company where
things change over time it's volatile
management volatile business the
interest coverage ratio will shift over
time so one easy fix then is of using
last year's interest coverage ratio is
to use an average over
time you could also argue that hey this
company has a nice operating income but
there are other things other fixed
charges you haven't considered it could
also be qualitative which is some
companies have been around a long time
they've always made their debt payments
you said that makes me feel good so I'll
concede up front that when you use an
interest coverage ratio to get a
synthetic rating you're probably missing
a lot of things that ratings agencies
use but let's see how much we're off
with Disney my synthetic rating was Tria
a right the actual rating was single a
and here the difference was easy to
explain if I used an average interest
coverage ratio for Disney over time
rather than just the 2013 operating
income which is a really good year my
interest my ratings very quickly started
to move towards single
a so what would I do I'd stay with the
single a rating because obviously the
AAA rating
overstates the credit standing for
Disney for V my synthetic rating is
double
A and snp's rating is a
minus what do you think I'm missing by
just using the interest coverage rate
ratio remind me again where Val is
located in Brazil and in 2013 people
thought that's a risky Market it's an
Emerging
Market ratings agencies factor in where
you're listed if you're a Nigerian
company you're going to struggle to make
it into the a even if you're a nice Safe
Company why because you're you know
you're thinking about country risk and
how it plays out if you're an Indian
company going to struggle to make it
past know double triple B sing a
minus so that difference is almost
entirely the country risk component
again what am I going to do I'm going to
stay with the S&P rating saying I hope
and pray that they've captured the
country risk in that a minus so I don't
have to worry about my cost of death and
for deut if you notice I didn't even
compute an interest coverage ratio why
was
that what's the interest expense for a
bank I'm not even sure what it measures
right because when you put deposits in a
bank and they're fixed rate you have a
fixed deposit the bank pays you an
interest expense so with banks interest
coverage ratios become almost useless in
judging ratings you know what the
biggest single determinant for ratings
for a Bankers is the regulatory Capital
ratios if they they're over capitalized
with a lot of capital they get good
ratings if they're a bank that is viewed
as very dicey it's you know regulatory
cap then your ratings are going to be
much lower so if you want to create a
synthetic ratings table for a bank it'll
almost entirely be driven by tier one
tier 2 tier three capital ratios I've
never bothered I just take the rating
banks are almost always going to be
rated and I use it to get my cost of
debt now for
bookscape I have no choice I have only a
synthetic rating I take the 1.3% default
spread add it to my rcre rate I come up
with a cost of debt of
4.05% I'm almost there I've got a cost
of debt for every company let me do that
for [__] Motors just to complete the
process for T Motors I did not have an
actual rating unlike Val where I trusted
the ratings agency to get the country
risk I had a synthetic rating the
default spread I got for the synthetic
rating was 70% so if I treated TARTA
Motors as like any other us company and
I gave them I would stop there but it's
an Indian company and here the
unfairness kick kicks in again to get
the cost of debt for automotives I had
two default spreads one for the company
and one for the
country in a sense you see what you know
what I'm reversing right how do I get
the risk free rate in rupees I start
with the government bond rate and backed
out the default spread now I'm adding it
back because T mes can't borrow a rate
lower than the Indian government The
Sovereign risk is in the in rupee terms
and I'm coming up you're saying why
didn't you do this for Val because I
actually had a rating for Val and I was
doing everything in US dollars if I were
doing things in R and I had a synthetic
rating for Val I would do the same
thing
yes yeah so in India for instance if you
get the local chrysal is the local
ratings agency that rates Indian
companies relative to other Indian
companies a AAA from chrysal is not a
AAA from S&P or Moody it's a AAA
relative to the Indian government so you
can add that default spread but you then
have to add it to the bond rate don't
add to the risk free rate you got to
bring in that government default risk so
I've got a pre-tax cost of borrowing for
all of my companies
right but here's where what governments
do affects my cost of borrowing how many
of you do your own
taxes I haven't done it yet it's looming
over me but sometime between now and
April 15 I'm going to open up Turbo Tax
which is a ripoff entity if you ever
know one the amount of add-ons they get
by the time you're done with your taxes
terrify me I don't even look at it
because I've got to file for five
different states why every one of my
kids is in a different state and I
happen to become the tax preparer for
them now how this happened
right but let's say you're doing taxes
and you run a
business you have a million dollars in
income and you have $100,000 in interest
expenses what are you allowed to do do
in Computing your
taxes you're allowed to deduct the
100,000 and Report 900,000 in taxable
income and pay taxes on that that is the
tax benefit of debt debt lowers your
taxable income it lowers your taxes and
in effect this is what it does if you
borrow money at
8% and your marginal tax rate we'll talk
about what the marginal tax rate and why
it it and only it matters is 40%
you're in effect paying 4.8% in taxes
you pay the 8% in taxes you save 40% in
tax in them why marginal because think
of the example I gave you you had a
million dollar in income and $100,000 in
interest expenses right so what do you
report as taxable income
900,000 think of way you saved on taxes
on the last $100,000 of income not the
first not the middle there's another tax
rate that floats around in corporate
finance and valuation called an
effective tax rate that's like an
average tax rate across all your income
you can't use that to do cost of debt
it's got to be a marginal tax rate where
will you find the marginal tax rate in
the tax
codes don't look for it in your company
it's got nothing to do with your company
so in the US right now at least in March
of
20225 it could be different in June
because there's a tax code working its
way through the federal marginal tax
rate is
21% you had state and local taxes you're
at about 20
25% if I borrow money in the US and I'm
a moneymaking company that's key right
because IRS doesn't mail you a check for
25% of Interest
expenses I'm effectively going to be
able to take whatever my borrowing rate
is and multiply it by 1 minus
.25 what you see here are the marginal
tax rates are used in November of 2013
you're saying why is the marginal tax
rate for Disney so high because in
2013 the US had one of the highest
corporate marginal tax rates in the
world it was the most dysfunctional tax
code written in history because we
written in a different time when us
companies basically had no choice but to
take it not only do the US have the
highest corporate marginal tax rate in
the world you had taxed on all of your
income globally at the US marginal tax
rate so if you made your money in Hong
Kong there's a corporate tax rate of 15%
at least in theory but the way legis
laters write tax law they don't think
through the
consequences you know how that extra tax
was supposed to be levied on you you had
business in Hong Kong you paid
15% the US tax rate was let's say 35 or
40% you were taxed on the difference but
only if you moved your money back from
Hong Kong I don't know what legislators
think would happen if you write this
kind of tax code so if you're a
multinational you you income all over
the world on which you're paying well
below 40% US government says when you
bring it back to the us we're going to
tax you what are you going to do you're
not going to bring it back to the US a
5-year-old could have thought through
this
consequence and in
2016 there was $2 trillion in what was
called trap cash Apple alone had $150
billion trapped outside the US trapped
in what sense because the minute they
brought it back so let me tell
tell me what I can do with the 150
billion if I'm
Apple I can invest it anywhere else in
the world I can leave it anywhere else
in the world here's what I cannot do I
cannot pay it as dividends or buy back
or use for BuyBacks for my shareholders
I cannot invest that money in the US
talk about perverse
consequences you have legislators
complaining that companies don't invest
enough in the US and then what do they
do they write this damn t
tax luckily and this is one of the the
there are lots of things about the 2017
tax reform I don't act this was one of
the things that was fixed so now if
you're are a multinational this is true
for the rest of the world in fact there
are only six countries that used to do
what the US did and you don't want to
know the names of the other five this
was not the company you wanted to hang
out with if you the rest of the world
was in this Glo on this on this system
of your tax wherever you do business and
you're done 20 2017 that law came in and
the other thing that 2017 of course
changed was the marginal tax rate it
went from 35% the federal level down to
21% which basically brought the marginal
tax rate in the US almost to exactly the
global median much of Europe is around
25% with the honorable or the
dishonorable exception
of
Ireland right and how they manage to
hang out at a 12% and are allowed to
stay in the EU I don't know because this
is clearly a setup for money moving to
Ireland and seems like a loophole in an
EU where you have one country at 12% as
they bring in East EUR Eastern Europe
This is starting to expand there are
lots of Eastern European countries with
the marginal tax rate is 10% 12% money
Finds Its way to low tax
locals business might not but money will
the marginal tax rate is essentially the
tax rate and you'll notice it's 36.1%
for do share
29.4% you're saying that is a very weird
number you know what happens to
corporate tax rates there's a tax rate
and then there's a onetime add-on
because the country is having a you know
deficit problem supposed to be one time
37 years later you look and say how come
we've been paying it for nothing ever is
one time it kind of stays on so you get
these strange looking marginal tax rates
and there's my after tax cost to debt
take a look at those numbers and
remember what the cost of equity look
like for each of these companies and
what's the first thing that jumps out at
you this is a really
low way I mean low cost and that's
always going to be true when you do this
for your companies don't be surprised
the after tax cost of borrowing is well
below the cost of equity but don't take
the next step and say that must me Deb
is better than Equity we haven't gotten
that step yet but debt is always going
to be cheaper than Equity even before a
tax benefit and you kick that in the
only part of the world where you're not
going to be able to do the one minus is
parts of the Middle
East where interest is not tax
deductible more for religious reasons
they don't want companies borrowing
money to pass through much of the rest
of the world there is a tax benefit to
borrow so you got a rating what do you
use the rating for to come up with a
default spread to the question of do
default spreads change over time well
there's your answer this actually tracks
default spreads at the start of every
year and you can see if you take let's
pick a particular R let's take Triple B
Triple B is investment grade it's that
magical cut off and we'll talk about why
companies don't want to fall below
Triple B though that those those U
constraints have become looser so if you
take Triple B you can look across 2021
2022 2023 and you can see that between
2021 and 2023 the spreads went up and at
the start of 2025
default spreads have decreased if you
get a chance go look at implied Equity
risk premiums and you're going to see
the same pattern why because the same
people in both markets if they get
scared in one they're going to get
scared in the other default spreads do
change over time so you want updated
defa spread you can use my numbers from
the start of 2025 but I'm also going to
give you the place I go to get those
updated
spreads and if you want to update it
between now and may try it out it's not
a big deal you download the spreadsheet
they give you the spreads on the start
of every month if you go to Bloomberg
you can get at the start of every day
it's a little bit of over Overkill but
Thea spreads do
change and in some years they change a
lot more than in
others remember the co year this is what
theault spreads did during the course of
the year
there's
214 February 14th of 2020 you know what
the significance of that date was that
was the date that the Italian government
announced that they' found covid cases
on the Italian Mainland and there was no
connection to either China China or
cruise ships so we woke up to the fact
that this is a pandemic it's everywhere
and between February 14th and March 20th
the world melted
down look at what happened to default
spreads they they doubled across the
board triaa and in fact the lower
ratings were hit even more so if your
cost capital for a company on February
14th was based on a rating and the
rating didn't change your cost of debt
would still have changed and of course
it should the world's getting riskier
it's getting more difficult to raise
money but luckily for us that crisis
passed quickly at least in the markets
and the default spreads by the end of
the year come back down perhaps not to
pre-crisis levels but to levels pretty
close so during some years the spreads
will change so here's my task for you
right you've got a company and now that
your quiz is behind
you look up the rating for your company
where are you going to find it go to
Google search this is one this is where
Google search is useful right the old
days you'd have to go find the Moody
Pages go to Google Search and say
company Bond rating and 95% of the time
if your company has a rating it'll be
that somewhere right if you want to use
Gro or you want to use Gemini be my
guest Chach PT this is a good way to use
those as tools so if you have rate if
you can't find it don't try to get blood
out of a Stones so I'm going to keep
looking 16 days on Google search will
not help you find a rating for a company
if it doesn't have a rating in the first
place use the interest coverage ratio
you know it's I'll send you this little
Excel spreadsheet all it does is it's
got the lookup table built into it you
enter the abbit and the interest expense
for your company it'll compute the
interest coverage ratio along the way
I'll ask you is your company a big
company or small company risky so I'll
make you and I'll go to the lookup table
come up with the rating and the default
spread is updated to the January 2025
numbers if you have a US company for the
moment use a marginal tax rate of 25%
why for the moment because there stock
at least in the tax Cod I don't think
it's going to happen of lowering the
marginal tax rate at least for
subsets of us companies I think we're
pretty much you know because if it this
would have become a much more
consequential
question if the election had gone a
different way because remember the tax
code that was fixed in 2017 sunsets at
the end of
2025 so if nothing is done in 2026 the
marginal tax rate for US companies would
jump back up to about
40% so the best case scenario now might
be it stays at 25% use 25% if you're in
a different country the saying how do I
find a tax
code I actually stole a table I found on
PWC I told them I'm stealing it no send
a lawyer after me if you want which
actually lists corporate tax rates by
country which is an
immense plus because otherwise you have
to know how to read 50 different
languages to go through the tax codes
list the corporate tax rate by country
it's on my web page you can download
I'll send it as a link after the know on
the email after the class but use that
marginal tax
rate couple of final loose scents that I
want to tie up before we end this
discussion so we've talked about two
ways of raising Capital debt and equity
and for most of you that's it that's
what you'll find but for a couple of
your companies or a few of your
companies there will be this pain in the
neck of what I call hybrid Securities
what are hybrid Securities they're part
debt part
Equity the simplest example of this is
convertible debt what is convertible
debt it's traditional debt was is an
interest rate and a principal payment
but you can convert the debt into Equity
if share prices go up that's an equity
option that is really Equity it's hybrid
because it has both in there the other
is this pain in the neck security called
preferred stock which in the US is just
debt with the name Equity attached to it
preferred stock has a fixed dividend
it's different Latin American preferred
stock is this common stock without
voting rights us preferred stock you get
a fixed
dividend so just like a coupon the only
reason you can't treat it as debt is
that coupon is not that dividend is not
tax deductible so if you throw it in
with thatt and put a one minus t on it
you're going to understate it so some
bad news if you have a company with a
significant amount of preferred stock
you have to open up a third part to your
cost cap Equity debt preferred stock not
a big deal and the cost of preferred
stock is just the preferred dividend
yeld it's the preferred dividend divided
by the preferred stock price okay I told
you not to pick Financial Service
Company so you're taking 80% of the
preferred stockholders off the map
because banks are among the biggest
issues of preferred stock you know
why because the regulatory authorities
allow them to treat preferred Equity as
equity in that tier one tier two it's a
very expensive way of borrowing money
because you don't get the tax advantage
but you let get to do this virtue dance
of I issued Equity I'm a safer Bank when
in fact you've issued debt and you don't
even get the tax benefit so if you have
those then deal with them and move on
one final point the weights that you
need is an absolutely categorical first
principal rule you have to be market
value weights as opposed to what those
book values you see on balance
sheets and you know how much of it
tussle this is when I when when you try
to get
CFOs to buy into it for a very simple
reason if you look at the background of
all of the CFOs in the face of the Earth
where did most of them start
off 48,000 CFOs every company I'm sure
is a CFO what was their usually their
starting point what what discipline did
they started there were accountants
right it's changing maybe in the US you
might have some mbas become CFOs of but
the bulk of the CFOs in the world are
accountants and I don't blame them
they're very attached to their balance
sheets and they come up with every
conceivable excuse for why they want to
use book values and I'm going to give
you the ammunition to push back because
you're going to run to seef why can't I
use Book value weights first they will
tell you book value is more reliable
than market value you know why it
doesn't change as much in fact we know
exactly how often Book value changes
for us company how often does Book value
change four times a year every time you
do a cly report you want make book
values even more reliable let's go to
annual forget about the quarterly in
fact why do we even annual let's do it
once every 10 years it's absurd but to
argue that something is reliable while
the world is changing around you I think
misuses the word reliable Book value is
not more reliable it's actually less
reliable because it never changes second
they will tell you that they're just
being conservative they are accountants
and I'm being conservative but here's
why that doesn't work take your company
and try to estimate the cost of capital
first with market value weights and then
with Book value weights let's say this's
debt and
Equity what's generally going to happen
to your debt ratio when you go from
market value to book value for almost
every
company Book value of equity most
companies is one quarter one5 1110th the
market value right so when you use Book
value weights debt is always going to
look more weighted 30% 40% you take
Netflix you book Debt ratios you come up
with like 55% debt ratios you put in a
55% de debt ratio into your cost of
capital what are you going to do to your
cost of capital you're going to pull it
down this is not conservative it's exact
opposite Book value is not more reliable
it's not more conservative and if you're
Computing return Capital we come back
and talk it's true we use book values
but for a very different reason there
are no good reasons or even semi good
reasons for using Book value use market
value
weights so next session when we start
we're going to talk about estimating the
market value of debt so we can get these
debt
ratios and then we will move on to
measuring return so if you haven't read
your case which I know you've had other
things on your plate please read the
case you looking at me like what case
there was a case you got so read the
case before you come to class next
session because it will
help it's a market now the other bonds
that are traded with that ring right
got
your
con Enterprise
Value well I was saying
that tell me how that played out in the
de
ratio equity which is not so de firm
value
when it plays out
in that's perfectly okay stay all the
way
through OST you're going to get it's
going to be roughly the same but you got
to be consistent all the way through
even if the net differ Nega you got you
got
so when you're starting for this firm
value that's like Enterprise Value Plus
like non-operational assets right like
it's not equivalent it's it includes
cash so the non-operating assets an
entirely different c f that should be
neither in firm value nor an entprise
value because complete MCH but cash is
usually the difference between firm
value and Enterprise but if you look at
a company's Financial balance sheet the
asset include cash this part of asset so
the debt is the grow SC and of course
you could act like you have no cash and
met that out but you know that's that's
okay as long as you recognize that
that's how you ended up with no
put into the
risky even if
large for you you might be small cap and
emerging you're going to end up in the
risky call any because remember two
lookup tables that is to tell me whether
I use the first lookup table which is
for Bild sa for companies or the second
one you're going to end up in the second
table no matter what so how
many you can take everything that a
company does the question is which ones
actually remember all these ratios are
highly Corr with each other so if you
have 16 ratios and the correlation
across the ratios is 93% you might as
well use one ratio because when that
ratio goes up all of the other ratios
are going to move with it it's not a
question of whether other ratios matter
but the interest coverage ratio captures
the information so dat to fix charges is
almost perfectly C the interest coverage
so the interest coverage ratio decreases
that when it's going to decrease as well
it becomes a redundant R I've already
brought so you're looking for ratios
which carry information that's not in
the interest
c those ratios
SI of the company for one of those
things right so we're bringing
separately cutable
variable you would expect company with
more volatile earnings to have a lower
interest coverage Rao if you want to
build that in create an interest
coverage ratio for Vol earnings
companies and what that will show is you
have to get a higher interest compan
rati to get the
same so mostly other ratios are kind of
irr so it's really level of earning so
vol
earnings maybe the level of debt you
have the debt to Capital ratio but
outside of that there's almost no other
ratio that's going to help you me the
ultimate Z score brings in things like
for working care Rao but that's a
different their that objective there is
to figure out whether you're distress or
not that's not the end game
yeah if you can price a bond in fact
when I go through it if you price the
bond it's going to look very familiar
because you have Book value of debt and
the interest expense and you have a
maturity for the debt I know but it's do
way it changes
right yeah that's why the book value so
because how the price of a bond change
when the interest rate changes and you
know how to compute the price of a bond
the interest rate goes up right you put
the new interest rate exactly the same
process so market value Deb is is
actually Bond
pricing extrapolated into book de but
how can you know the appar maturity it's
it's good to maturity of the you don't
need the Y you don't need the yield to
maturity I mean the current you don't
need any of that right because you
already have the pre-tax cost of debt
which should be you know the coupon that
so you know the coupon you know the face
value and you have the pre-tax cost of
De already you're ready so there's no
need to compute what the maturity would
be this should be year to maturity and
you're going to use that to come up with
the present value of the
that what about back the B we use the
same thing right we use the same yeah if
you going to value that but we never do
that ratios for BS no I mean the back
loan of the company is considered debt
as well that's why that's what Market
when you talk about marking loans to
Market that's all you're doing you
taking the loan payments du you take the
face value of the loan and you discount
them back at today
cost of debt for that loan reflecting
higher interest rates more default risk
but guess what if you loan money to
somebody in 2020 you look at that same
loan today the market value of that loan
will be significantly below the book
value of the loan the interest rates
have gone up and you got to take the
problem so that means if you want to use
this method you have to all the bonds
and the
back you don't need to you just can
treat them as an agre right so you know
the
the Agate coupon because it's the
interest expense in your income
statement right where does the aggregate
coupon go it goes into an interest
expense in the income statement right it
doesn't disappear into so if you look at
the total interest
expense on the income statements a
collective coupon slin rate that you
paid on all of the existing lws right so
that becomes if you look at the balance
sheet look at the book value debt that's
a collective value according to
accountant of the face value the
Deb wa maturity right most companies
will tell you what when in the footnotes
oh okay in fact Blom if you go in and
type in crpr it'll give you the weighted
maturity of the debt because it's public
information you know because the loans
are not in thin air so they give you a
weight of maturity so you take the
interest expense you take the book value
of debt you take the weight of maturity
and you apply today's pre-tax cost to
debt you got market value de
last
question so if you want to use a to